when the right song becomes a part of
the right movie it stays with us forever
you can never hear that song again
without thinking about its movie partner
that is the power of music although most
of the nominees were able to make it to
los angeles there are a pair joining us
from sweden
so here are the nominees for best song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the black decided
oh my god um i did not expect to win
this award i am
so so so so grateful not only to win but
to be a part of such
an important important story so thank
you so much
thank you to the academy i've always
wanted to say that
um and of course my collaborators dmile
and tierra thomas the song wouldn't be
what it was without them
of course i have to thank god for giving
us these gifts and
my parents my beautiful mother who's
here with me today and
my father at home all those days of
listening to
sly in the family stone and curtis
mayfield and marvin gaye they really
paid off so thank you dad
thank you so much to archie and shaka
king and everybody that was involved in
this movie and
gave me the call and gave us the call to
to do this record i'm
so so grateful um i just want to say
this
you know musicians filmmakers i believe
we have an
opportunity and a responsibility to me
to tell the truth and to to write
history the way that it was
and how it connects us um to today
and and what we see going on in the
world today
and um yeah i'm just i have no words i'm
i'm just so
so so happy and grateful and um
yeah knowledge is power music is power
and as long as i'm standing i'm always
going to fight for us i'm always going
to fight
for my people and fight for what's right
and i think that's what music does and
that's what storytelling does so thank
you so much thank you
you